There's no denying that human babies are cute
- but even other species tend to have adorable
infants. So why has science conditioned us
to find babies so precious? Is there something
specific that triggers our urge to hold and
squeeze them?
Interestingly, studies have found that macaque
monkeys pay little attention to newborn faces,
leading researchers to believe that the 'cute
feeling' may be an entirely human trait. Unlike
many other species, once born, human babies
are completely dependent on their parents
for survival. As a result, humans have adapted
to find certain traits aesthetically pleasing
and downright adorable, in effort to increase
interaction, care and protection from parents.
This in turn enhances offspring survival,
and perpetuates our species. But what exactly
makes something seem 'cute'?
Known as Baby Schema, scientists have come
up with a set of tested traits that make something
appear cute. These include a large rounded
head relative to the body, large eyes below
the midline of the face, protruding cheeks,
a big forehead, round body and soft surfaces.
Awwwh! And no doubt, our species is born with
fully grow large eyes, almost full sized brains,
soft skin, big cheeks and round bodies.
In fact, in tests where baby photos are manipulated
to have more baby schema traits - whether
they're human babies or dogs and cats, for
example - they are rated as cuter, and participants
felt a stronger motivation to take care of
these babies. Even when the front of cars
were altered in accordance to the baby schema
- like making the headlights become larger
to mimic big eyes - participants experienced
a more positive response.
It turns out, it's all in our head. When viewing
babies with enhanced baby schema proportions,
the mesocorticolimbic system of our brain
is activated. These parts of the brain enhance
the anticipation of a reward, and can lead
to a sense of enjoyment, motivation to care
for something and the urge to cuddle or hold
an object.
But what about things that...aren't...so cute?
In fact, some creatures are downright ugly?
So what does science have to say about these?
Our friends at Earth Unplugged have answered
this very question in our collaboration on
animals - so click on the screen, or on the
link in the description to find out. Huge
thanks to the team at Earth Unplugged for
providing us with all this footage. Go watch
their video and follow them for even more
amazing content.
And subscribe to AsapSCIENCE for more weekly science videos!